alors aujourd'hui la deuxième raison
pour laquelle on se retrouve
c'est parce que nous allons ensemble
visionner et bien un documentaire
projection particulière ce soir là au
grenier à sel de trappes certains
spectateurs vont se voir à l'écran ils
ont été filmées lors de leur
participation au concours toi même tu
filmé cette aventure sinon c'est
vraiment une époque une aventure superbe
c'est vraiment une expérience à faire
pour tous les jeunes ou les jeunes ont
envie de s'exprimer mais on connaît pas
la meilleure façon de faire et eux nous
ont donné la une d une des meilleures
façons il est là une des meilleures
aussi parce que on utilise tous les
jours c'est notre téléphone j'ai appris
que c'était un concours vidéo et moi ce
qui est cinéma/vidéo bas sans parfum
m'intéresse en plein pendant plusieurs
mois ces jeunes ont réalisé des
courts-métrages encadrés par les équipes
de youtube 90 secondes autour d'un même
message la fraternité
le réalisateur mathieu mast ans et qui
sait parmi eux et en ressort 40 minutes
de documentaires l'idée c'est de voir un
peu les coulisses de la tournée donc les
ateliers avec les jeunes qui consistait
à un volet pédagogique un volet plus
ateliers de travail où on allait
travailler ensemble à créer des vidéos
elles les équipes de youtube seront à
nouveau dans l'école lunel était 2017
les trappistes les attendent déjà